you guys know henry from minutephysics
right
well he and i just made a video on a
certain quantum mechanical topic
bell's inequalities it's a really
mind-warping topic that not enough
people know about and even though it's a
quantum thing it's based on some
surprisingly simple math
and you should definitely check it out
for this video we have in mind those
viewers who actually want to learn some
quantum mechanics more deeply
and obviously it's a huge topic nowhere
near the scope of a single video
but the question we asked was what topic
could we present
that's not meant to be some eye-catching
piece of quantum weirdness
but which actually lays down some useful
foundations for anyone who
you know wants to learn this field what
topic would set the right intuitions for
someone before
they dove into say the fineman lectures
well a natural place to start where
quantum mechanics itself started
is light specifically if you want to
learn quantum you have to have an
understanding of waves and how they're
described mathematically
and what we'd like to build to here is
the relationship between the energy in a
purely classical wave
and the probabilities that govern
quantum behavior
in fact we'll actually spend most of the
time talking through the pre-quantum
understanding of light
since that sets up a lot of the relevant
wave mechanics the thing is a lot of
ideas from quantum mechanics like
describing states as superpositions with
various amplitudes and phases
come up in the context of classical
waves in a way that doesn't involve any
of the quantum weirdness
people might be familiar with this also
helps to appreciate what's actually
different in quantum mechanics
namely certain restrictions on how much
energy these waves can have
how they behave when measured and
quantum entanglement though we won't
cover entanglement in this video
so we'll start with the late 1800s
understanding of light
as waves in the electromagnetic field
here let's break that down a bit
the electric field is a vector field and
that means every point in space has some
arrow attached to it
indicating the direction and strength of
the field now the physical meaning of
those arrows is that if you have some
charged particle in space
there's going to be a force on that
particle in the direction of the arrow
and it's proportional to the length of
the arrow and the specific charge of the
particle
likewise the magnetic field it's another
vector field where now
the physical meaning of each arrow is
that when a charged particle is moving
through that space there's going to be a
force perpendicular to both
its direction of motion and to the
direction of the magnetic field
and the strength of that force is
proportional to the charge of the
particle
its velocity and the length of the
magnetic field arrow
for example a wire with a current of
moving charges next to a magnet is
either pushed or pulled by that magnetic
field
a kind of culmination of the 19th
century physics understanding of how
these two fields work
are maxwell's equations which among
other things describe how each of these
fields can cause a change to the other
specifically what maxwell's equations
tell us is that when the electric field
arrows seem to be forming a loop
around some region the magnetic field
will be increasing
inside that region perpendicular to the
plane of the loop
and symmetrically such a loop in the
magnetic field corresponds to a change
in the electric field within it
perpendicular to the plane of the loop
now the specifics for how exactly these
equations work is
really beautiful and worth a full video
on its own but all you need to know for
now
is that one natural consequence of this
mutual interplay and how changes to one
field cause changes to the other in its
neighboring regions
is that you get these propagating waves
where the electric field and magnetic
fields are oscillating perpendicular to
each other
and perpendicular to the direction of
propagation
when you hear the term electromagnetic
radiation which refers to things like
radio waves and visible light
this is what it's talking about
propagating waves in both the electric
and magnetic fields of course it's now
almost mainstream to know of light as
electromagnetic radiation
but it's neat to think about just how
surprising this was in maxwell's time
that these fields that have to do with
forces on charged particles and
magnets not only have something to do
with light but that what light is is a
propagating wave as these two fields
dance with each other causing this
mutual oscillation of increasing and
decreasing field strength
with this as a visual let's take a
moment to lay down the math used to
describe
waves it'll still be purely classical
but ideas that are core to quantum
mechanics like superposition
amplitudes phases all of these come up
in this context
and i would argue with a clearer
motivation for what they actually mean
take this wave and think of it as
directed straight out of the screen
towards your face and let's go ahead and
ignore the magnetic field right now
just looking at how the electric field
oscillates and also we're only going to
focus on one of these vectors
oscillating in the plane of the screen
which we'll think of as the
x y plane if it oscillates horizontally
like this
we say that the light is horizontally
polarized
so the y component of this electric
field is
0 at all times and we might write the x
component as something like cosine
of two pi times f t where f
represents some frequency and t is time
so if f was one for example that means
it takes exactly
one second for this cosine function to
go through a full cycle
for a lower frequency that would mean it
takes more time for the cosine to go
through its full cycle
as the value t increases the inside of
this cosine function
increases more slowly also we're going
to include another term in here
fee called the phase shift which tells
us where this vector is in its cycle at
time
t equals 0. you'll see why that matters
in just a moment
now by default cosine only oscillates
between negative
one and one so let's put another term in
front a
that gives us the amplitude of this wave
one more thing just to make things look
a little more like they often do in
quantum mechanics
instead of writing it as a column vector
like this i'm going to separate
it out into two different components
using these symbols called cats
this ket here indicates a unit vector in
the horizontal direction
and this ket over here represents a unit
vector in the vertical direction
if the light is vertically polarized
meaning the electric field is wiggling
purely in the up and down direction its
equation might look like
this where the horizontal component is
now zero
and the vertical component is a cosine
with some frequency
amplitude and a phase shift now if you
have two distinct waves
two ways of wiggling through space over
time that solve maxwell's equations
then adding both of these together gives
another valid wave
at least in a vacuum that is at each
point in time
add these two vectors tip to tail to get
a new vector
doing this at all points in space and
all points in time
gives a new valid solution to maxwell's
equations
at least this is all true in a vacuum
this is because maxwell's equations in a
vacuum are what's called
linear equations they're essentially a
combination of derivatives acting on the
electric and magnetic fields
to give zero so if one field f1
satisfies this equation
and another field f2 satisfies it then
their sum
f1 plus f2 also satisfies it since
derivatives are linear
so the sum of two or more solutions to
maxwell's equations
is also a solution to maxwell's
equations
this new wave is called a superposition
of the first two
and here superposition essentially just
means some or in some context
weighted sum since if you include some
kind of amplitude and phase shift in
each of these components it can still be
called a superposition of the two
original vectors
now right now the resulting
superposition is a wave wiggling in the
diagonal direction
but if the horizontal and vertical
components were out of phase with each
other
which might happen if you increase the
phase shift in one of them
there some might instead trace out some
sort of ellipse
and in the case where the phases are
exactly 90 degrees out of sync with each
other
and the amplitudes are both equal this
is what we call circularly polarized
light
this by the way is why it's important to
keep track not just of the amplitude in
each direction
but also of the phase it affects the way
the two waves
add together
that's also an important idea that
carries over to quantum and underlies
some of the things that look confusing
at first
and here's another important idea we're
describing waves by adding together the
horizontal and vertical components
but we could also choose to describe
everything with respect to different
directions
i mean you could describe waves as some
superposition of the diagonal
and the anti-diagonal directions in that
case
vertically polarized light would
actually be a superposition
of these two diagonal wiggling
directions at least when both are in
phase with each other and they have the
same magnitude
now the choice of which directions you
write things in terms of is called a
basis
and which basis is nicest to work with
well that typically depends on what
you're actually doing with the light
for example if you have a polarizing
filter like that from a set of polarized
sunglasses
the way these work is by absorbing the
energy from electromagnetic oscillations
in some particular direction a
vertically oriented polarizer for
example
would absorb all of the energy from
these waves along the horizontal
directions
at least classically that's how you
might think about it so
if you're analyzing light and it's
passing through a filter like this
it's nice to describe it with respect to
the horizontal and vertical directions
that way what you can say is that
whatever light passes through the filter
is just the vertical component of the
original wave
but if you had a filter oriented say
diagonally well then it would be
convenient to describe things as a
superposition
of that diagonal direction and its
perpendicular anti-diagonal direction
these ideas will carry over almost word
for word to the quantum case
quantum states much like this wiggling
direction of our wave
are described as a superposition of
multiple base states
where you have many choices for what
base states to use
and just like with classical waves the
components of such a superposition will
have both an amplitude and a phase of
some kind
and by the way for those of you who do
read more into quantum mechanics you'll
find that these components are actually
given using a single complex number
rather than a cosine expression like
this one one way to think of this is
that complex numbers are just a very
convenient and natural mathematical way
to encode an
amplitude and a phase with a single
value that can make things a little
confusing because it's hard to visualize
a pair of complex numbers
which is what would describe a
superposition of two base states
but you can think about the use of
complex numbers throughout quantum
mechanics as a result of its underlying
wavy nature
and this need to encapsulate the
amplitude and the phase for each
direction
okay just one quick point before getting
into the quantum look at one of these
waves
and focus just on the electric field
portion like we were before
classically we think about the energy of
a wave like this as being proportional
to the square of its amplitude
and i want you to notice how well this
lines up with the pythagorean theorem
if you were to describe this wave as a
superposition of a horizontal component
with amplitude ax and a vertical
component
with amplitude a y then its energy
density
is proportional to ax squared plus a y
squared
and you can think of this in two
different ways either it's because
you're adding up the energies
of each component in the superposition
or
it's just that you're figuring out the
new amplitude using the pythagorean
theorem
and taking the square isn't that nice
in the classical understanding of light
you should be able to dial this energy
up and down continuously however you
want by changing the amplitude of the
wave
but what physicists started to notice in
the late 19th and early 20th centuries
was that this energy actually seems to
come in discrete amounts
specifically the energy of one of these
electromagnetic waves
always seems to come as an integer
multiple of a specific constant times
the frequency of that wave
we now call this constant planck's
constant commonly denoting it with the
letter
h physically what this means is that
whenever this wave trades its energy
with something else like an electron
the amount of energy it trades off is
always an integer multiple of h
times its frequency importantly this
means there is some minimal
non-zero energy level for waves of a
given frequency
hf if you have an electromagnetic wave
with this frequency and energy
you cannot make it smaller without
eliminating it entirely
that feels weird when the conception of
a wave is a nice continuously
oscillating vector field
but that's not how the universe works as
late 19th and early 20th century
experiments started to expose
in fact i've done a video about this
called the origin of quantum mechanics
however it's worth noting that this
phenomenon is actually common in waves
when they're constrained in certain ways
like in pipes or instrument strings and
it's called harmonics
what's weird is that electromagnetic
waves do this in free space
even when they're not constrained and
what do we call an electromagnetic wave
with this minimal possible energy
a photon but like i said the math used
to describe
classical electromagnetic waves carries
over to describing a photon
it might have say a 45 degree diagonal
polarization
which can be described as a
superposition of a purely horizontal
state and a purely vertical state
where each one of these components has
some amplitude and phase
and with a different choice in bases
that same state might be described as a
superposition
of two other directions all of this is
stuff that you would see if you started
reading more into quantum mechanics
but this superposition has a different
interpretation than before
and it has to let's say you were
thinking of this diagonally polarized
photon kind of classically
and you said it has an amplitude of one
unit for some appropriate unit system
well that would make the hypothetical
amplitudes of its horizontal and
vertical components
each the square root of one half and
like henry said the energy of a photon
is this special constant
h times its frequency and because in a
classical setting energy is proportional
to the square of the amplitude of this
wave
it's tempting to think of half of the
energy as being in the horizontal
component
and half of it as being in the vertical
component but waves of this frequency
cannot have half the energy of a photon
i mean
the whole novelty of quantum here is
that energy comes in these discrete
indivisible chunks so these components
with an imagined amplitude of 1 over the
square root of 2
could not exist in isolation and you
might wonder
what exactly they mean well let's get
experimental about it
if you were to take a vertically
oriented polarizing filter
and shoot this diagonally polarized
photon right at it
what do you think would happen
classically the way you'd interpret the
superposition
is that the half of its energy in the
horizontal direction
would be absorbed but because energy
comes in these discrete photon packets
it either has to pass through with all
of its energy or get absorbed entirely
and if you actually did this experiment
about half the time the photon goes
through entirely
and about half the time it gets absorbed
entirely
and it appears to be random whether a
given photon passes through or not
if it does pass through forcing it to
make a decision like this
actually changes it so that its
polarization is oriented along the
filter's direction
this is analogous to the classic
schrodinger's cat setup you have
something that's in a superposition of
two states
but once you make a measurement of that
superposition
forcing it to interact with an observer
in a way where each of those two states
would behave differently
from the perspective of that observer
this superposition collapses
to be entirely in one state or entirely
in another
dead or alive horizontal or vertical
one pretty neat way to see this in
action which henry and i talk about in
the other video
is to take several polarized sunglasses
or some other form of polarizing filters
and start by holding two of them between
you and some light source
if you rotate them to be 90 degrees off
from each other
the light source is blacked out
completely or at least with perfect
filters it would be
because all of the photons passing
through that first one
are polarized vertically so they
actually have a zero percent chance
of passing a filter oriented
horizontally
but if you insert a third filter
oriented at a 45 degree angle between
the two
it actually lets more light through and
what's going on here is that
50 percent of the photons passing that
vertical filter
will also pass through the diagonal
filter and once they do
they're going to be changed to have a
purely diagonal polarization
and then once they're in that state they
have a 50 50 chance of passing through
the filter
oriented at 90 degrees so even though
zero percent of the photons passing
through the first would pass through
that last if nothing was in between
by introducing another filter 25 of them
now pass through all three
now that's something that you could not
explain unless that middle filter
forces the photons to change their
states and that experiment by the way
becomes
all the weirder when you dig into the
specific probabilities
for angles between 0 and 45 degrees and
that's actually what we talked about in
the other video for example
one specific value we focus on there is
the probability
that a photon whose polarization is 22.5
degrees
off the direction of a filter is going
to end up passing through that filter
again it's helpful to think of this wave
as having an amplitude of 1
and then you'd think of the horizontal
component as having amplitude
sine of 22.5 degrees which is around
0.38
and the vertical component would have an
amplitude cosine of 22.5 degrees
which is around 0.92
classically you might think of its
horizontal component as having
energy proportional to 0.38 squared
which is around 0.15 likewise you might
think of the vertical component
as having an energy proportional to 0.92
squared
which comes out to be around 0.85 and
like we said before
classically this would mean if you pass
it through a vertical filter
15 of its energy is absorbed in the
horizontal direction
but because the energy of light comes in
these discrete quanta that cannot be
subdivided
instead what you observe is that 85 of
the time
the photon passes through entirely and
15
of the time it gets completely blocked
[Music]
now i want to emphasize that the wave
equations don't change
the photon is still described as a
superposition of two oscillating
components
each with some phase and amplitude and
these are often encoded using a single
complex number
the difference is that classically the
squares of the amplitudes of each
component tells you the amount of that
wave's energy
in each direction but with quantized
light at this minimal non-zero energy
level
the squares of those amplitudes tell you
the probabilities
that a given photon is going to be found
to have all of its energy
in one direction or not also these
components could still have some kind of
phase difference
just like with classical waves photons
can be circularly polarized
and there exist polarizing filters that
only let through photons that are
polarized circularly
say in the clockwise direction or rather
they let through all photons
probabilistically where the
probabilities are determined by
describing each one of those photons as
a superposition
of the clockwise and counterclockwise
states and then the square of the
amplitude of the clockwise component
gives you the desired probability
photons are of course just one quantum
phenomenon one where we initially
understood it as a wave thanks to
maxwell's equations and then as
individual particles or quanta
hence the name quantum mechanics but as
many of you well know there's a flip
side to this where many things that were
understood to come in discrete little
packets like electrons were discovered
to be governed by similar
wavy quantum mechanics in cases way more
general than this one photon
polarization example
quantum mechanical states are described
as some superposition of multiple base
states
and the superposition depends on what
basis you choose each component in this
superposition is given with an amplitude
and a phase
often encoded as a single complex number
and the need for this phase arises from
the wave nature of these objects
as with the photon example the choice of
how to measure these objects can
determine a set of base states
where the probability of measuring a
particle to be in one of these base
states
is proportional to the squares of the
amplitudes of these numbers
it's funny to think though that if the
wavy nature of electrons and other
particles was discovered first
we might instead refer to the whole
subject as harmonic mechanics
or something like that since the
weirdness there is not that waves come
in discrete units but that particles are
governed by wave equations
this video was supported in part by
brilliant and as viewers of this channel
know what i like about brilliant is that
they're a great complement
to passively watching educational videos
all of you here
want to learn more math or physics or
the math that prepares you for physics
and the only way to actually learn this
stuff is to actively grapple with
puzzles and
problem solving brilliant offers many
really well curated sequences of
problems that help you to master all
sorts of technical subjects
you all like physics clearly so i think
that you would enjoy their courses on
classical mechanics and gravitational
physics
and honestly group theory would give you
a really good foundation
but there are many other great courses
too especially in math
if you go to brilliant.org 3b1b
that one lets them know that you came
from here and also the first 200 people
that go to that link
are going to get 20 off the annual
brilliant premium subscription
that's the subscription i've been using
and it's actually really fun to have a
bank of these puzzles and problems
but of course for those of you who want
some more passive viewing don't forget
that henry and i just put out a video on
bell's inequalities over on minute
physics
if for some reason you haven't been
following minute physics these days and
i don't know why you wouldn't have been
the videos there have been really top
notch so definitely take a moment to
poke around the rest of his channel
[Music]
you